usually when people first see the
mannequin that kind of wondering you
know what does it do what's the purpose
of it
it has mouth it has teeth it has soft
gums it has a cheek because said we got
the same haircut as well my name is
Philip realice I am the Director of
Sales for Columbia dental for me we
supply dental mannequins to dental
schools we basically supplies their
first patient whether the train on
before they actually move on to like
patients the company started in 1917 so
next year the columbia dental one will
be a hundred years old the models the
mannequins are all assembled by hand we
spell well over a million teeth a year
we make a variety of models we provide
models that put tartar on the teeth we
make models that have a variety of
disease under the gums on the gums if
they need to they could do a narrow root
canal on the dog and cat as well we have
models that have absolutely no teeth at
all so they can learn how to do a
complete denture the reason why if this
actually looks this way we really didn't
want to put any gender in the manikin
and so it could be anybody the design of
it is based on what an average human
would look like as far as the size of
the head the ears the mouth opening the
softness of the gum tissue the only
thing that doesn't stimulate it may be
the bad breath but other than that it's
a great patient because it just
cooperates with you I've been with the
company for 41 years I have no idea that
I'll be working with dental mannequins
at all all these teeth my granddaughters
think I work for the tooth fairy
and so that really works out well
because if their parents forget to put
money under the pillow for a tooth
they'll tell mom just talk to the
grandpa he knows all he knows the tooth
fairy
you
[Music]